recording in progress
here
all right good morning and welcome
to why you need AI for decision making
for business strategies and applications
with Wharton online from the University
of Pennsylvania Wharton School
and my name is Stuart Creek I am with
simply learn we are the delivery partner
for Wharton
for this program
I will be taking you through the uh
program today but I will also be sharing
with you uh
words from
Don huesman
chairman emeritus of Wharton online
and we'll be asking a few questions
about you during the process
I'll also be um
taking you through what this program
offers why it's important why Ai and
business is important
and uh
will go through how the program works in
a little bit and I'll take some of your
questions toward the end to share with
you the cost and process
or uh engaging in the programs
last thing
and I will get started
so uh don heusman is going to be
speaking with us and he is the managing
director Emeritus for Wharton online so
let me let you hear from him
and
we will
bring him online here
and these are some of the recorded
remarks from a previous session we did
with him
sure thanks Stuart um I have been a
Wharton for a very long time actually in
multiple roles uh most recently I've
been the managing director for our
online learning initiatives they started
uh well this particular initiative
started uh around 2011 when the moocs
were new and exciting and the the dean
and the Provost to the University of
Pennsylvania asked Wharton to get
involved and the project was handed to
me and so we have been experimenting
with the various forms of online
education since then have uh still have
a variety of moocs that are done through
sort of self-study and then we've found
a lot of luck working with the
organizations like simply learn to bring
a more facilitated experience to the
world around current topics that are
being researched by Wharton faculty
so we have employed about a half of the
Wharton standing faculty in various
programs of study and this one in
particular brings together
I can't remember if it's six or seven of
our research faculty associated with
exploring Ai and machine learning
so what we're going to talk about today
is really about a business look at uh at
the field of artificial intelligence and
machine learning not so much in
engineering look but rather how to make
sense of AI as both a resource to manage
as a general manager in a business but
also as a an opportunity for bringing
your organization up the learning curve
into what is emerging as a new set of
Technologies for
augmenting our decision making processes
so that's a brief overview of how I got
to the table today uh Stuart I'll turn
it back over to you thank you
and as Don mentioned he's going to speak
about the evolving role of AI in
business as a
tool to add to the toolkit of
organizational managers
um
to
just as a preamble data drives the
economy as we we all know in the
transformation of business to the
digital domain uh it's only gotten
far faster during the pandemic where we
all instantly had to move to work from
home I remember an executive early in
the pandemic who said if they had told
us we needed all to work remotely we
would have told management it would take
six months and 10 million dollars to do
that and when it happened it took three
days with no budget so we've all had to
adapt to a new data-driven world
that was creeping up on us over the last
decade or two but now
kind of the environment we all live in
so Don how does
how does an organization deal with that
metamorphosis
so what we've been suggesting is that AI
is such a fast-moving field that it's
important to take kind of a portfolio
approach for a larger organization to
um
uh to begin to build capacity inside the
organization both to use data in its in
its structured forms but to use Ai and
experiment with AI to explore the vast
amount of data that is actually
unstructured so the amount of data that
has been
um
growing in our organizations in our data
warehouses is probably 80 percent now
unstructured and the intelligence in
that data is the gold we're looking at
the end of the rainbow in terms of
trying to use these new technologies to
to both test the hypotheses that form
the basis of our own thinking about our
businesses but also to manage uncertain
environments such as the kinds of
circumstances we find ourselves in
today as some of us emerge from covid
others are slow to emerge from covid
with War and the possibility of
recession looming next year that
uncertainty uh makes our usual
decision-making processes more
complicated and whatever we can do to
bring data to help us better test our
hypotheses and explore our decision
options uh is uh is worth the investment
of time for sure and of money
with that let me ask you Stuart for the
next slide
so this slide is from
a a report originally put together by
Mackenzie there's a similar report that
TCS in India is also
develops looking at
the critical role for
someone who stands between
an understanding of the business case of
the c-suite issues of the business
models that have been created and
launched in our organizations and the
data scientists so as I mentioned this
course that we've put together
around AI for decision making is not an
engineering course not intended to be
it's really uh intended to provide a
general manager what we're referring to
is that Central column your role as
someone who knows enough about the the
tools that are available and the the
nature of exploring structured
unstructured data that you can in fact
uh translate uh the information that is
coming out of your data stores and data
collection processes into a forecast
model or a decision-making model that
will help hone decisions that are made
at various levels of management inside
your organizations so the idea is to
at the end of this course to have you in
a position to understand enough about
the AI Technologies and machine learning
technology apologies that are taking
shape on the horizon to be able to help
c-suite Executives and Senior Management
at your organization form questions that
those data can in fact help inform so
it's that middle role that we're after
and trying to explore by looking at
cases of companies who are at the
Leading Edge of working with new models
to extract
real information out of the loose data
particularly that that's found in vast
new stores of unstructured data
um in that regard I might mention that
in the nature of unstructured data we
have a large collection of data that
comes to us through our email stores and
voicemail stores uh our uh video stores
our audio stores
the large quantities of data that are
generated by analytical processes that
run on our websites and that fill out a
profile of what customers are doing as
they move from exploration to purchase
all of these stores of data are
different than what we faced
some
20 years ago when we had relational
databases and spreadsheets and
tabular data that could be organized by
rows and columns and that could be used
in a more direct way to predict and to
drive spreadsheet forecasting models
either those that are based in Worlds of
uncertainty where we would rely more on
scenario planning and sensitivity
analysis
versus the optimization models that we
would turn to should there be a clear
set of of choices and expected forecasts
so all of that relied in years past on
the existence of relational database
Management systems and other forms of
structured data the new tools that are
emerging are intended to provide us a
way of mining the data that comes to us
in largely in structured forms and
that's the point of this course without
let me ask stored for the next slide
so we're going to show you a variety of
examples that come from
organizations that have successfully
used Ai and machine learning to develop
new sales and marketing strategies so
we'll be looking at the work that has
been done by modern marketing
organizations to develop a personalized
recommendation engines and to explore
other marketing strategies that are
informed by large transactional
databases and by large analytical
databases of of customer behavior that
augments our transactional data stores
we'll be looking at Finance applications
such as the ability in Midstream for an
organization that provides
e-commerce transactions for example
an identification of a pattern of
behavior by customer that might suggest
that there's fraud at work and to
intervene in the transaction to take
further steps to assure the security of
a transaction
that might look initially suspicious
and we'll look at a third dimension
calling on faculty who are associated
with uh our people analytics initiative
to examine
how in fact uh AI machine learning can
associate can can be used to help us
with that most critical Resource
Management task we all face which is
dealing with your
decisions around hiring around promotion
and around
managing performance so AI has a strong
role to play in that Dimension as well
but of course it is
also important to recognize the ethical
insecurity
issues that arise whenever we're using
technology in the management of people
which is as critical you know if not
more so than in the management of our
organizations through new sales and
marketing and financial processes
I was going to ask uh I was going to
make a quick mention of
a
webinar that we did with the
founder of zest money is a fintech firm
um
in India and
the reason I bring it up is that that
type of fintech firm which offers
microcredit or instant credit
to Consumers can only exist because of
AI
as you talked about finance and fraud
detection and that type of thing
um
it turns out that the flip side of that
is to determine who's a good credit risk
from all of that as you said
unstructured data about a consumer's
spending habits and
other history and when a consumer gives
permission to zest money
to mine into that it can come back and
say
these are the types of levels of
transactions that we think this person
is
capable of handling and repaying and
it's
it's an amazing type of environment so
that's another example of how AI
in one of these domains
has opened up new opportunities for
businesses
I just wanted to mention that one
and um
I'll let you get back just to build on
that story
one of the realities in uh in even the
G20 countries is the uh is the problem
we faced let's say in the United States
for example
of people who lack FICO credit scores
and therefore cannot qualify for a uh
for a prime rate based loan and this has
uh the deleterious effect of the of the
making worse uh The Divide between the
Haves and the have-nots because
individuals who might otherwise be
entirely credit worthy don't have the
FICO score to get that truck or to buy
uh a house or to build the kind of
wealth that translates from one
generation into the next right and yet
uh even though in the United States at
least 40 percent of households uh lack
uh FICO scores that would allow for a
prime rate based loan uh the terms of
the matter is the vast majority of those
individuals are in fact better worthy
and it is as a result of the application
of AI and machine learning and other
fintech tools that companies have been
in a position to underwrite uh the
credit worthiness of an individual
facing more traditional financial
institutions this is particularly
relevant of course even more so in parts
of the world where retail banking
doesn't have a strong route where the
you know the individuals don't have the
common practice of of um connecting with
a local Banker at a local branch it's
just in some parts of the world that
doesn't happen whether you know there
are vast areas where retail banking
isn't even available and therefore the
use of new technology for transaction
processing and for manager Financial
life becomes more critical yep and then
the example of building uh
credit worthiness for people who don't
have the traditional credit scores
um you know the effect of that for the
business is that they get a whole bunch
of new customers who expand their
revenue streams so it it works for
societal benefit individual consumer
benefit and business benefit all at once
so great
um so
in order to participate in this
revolution
people especially at the at the
managerial director level need to
really have an understanding of the
field and what it can do for them right
exactly and that that requires a certain
um technical exposure to the to the
terminology uh that the data scientists
and the I.T Engineers will be using uh
in uh building out and developing a
portfolio of AI or machine learning
projects at your company so we're hoping
that this course is a way for you to
level set you know with an understanding
of of some fundamental Technologies like
what constitutes Big Data what
constitutes AI how is machine learning
uh conceived of in contemporary projects
both internal to a larger company in
your applications Development Group but
for smaller and mid-sized companies what
might be available on the open market
from consultants and other supporting
organizations
we're hoping that you'll come out away
from this course Center understanding
the difference between supervised and
unsupervised deep learning and the cases
in which both forms of deep learning
algorithmic based
information processing is put in play by
development organizations
there as I mentioned with regards to our
concerns regarding HR applications there
are many ethical
circumstances and corporate
organizational risks that can be
associated with AI algorithms can be as
biased as individuals in decisions
around hiring and promotion and
performance
assessment and looking into the ways in
which
AI applications can either introduce and
spread bias in an undetected way or can
be in some circumstances
increasingly
murky and Trend and not transparent
around the processes or the data points
that lead to a particular AI
recommendation so all of those are
critically important issues for General
management to take into consideration
and for those in the nonprofit sector or
in the government sector there are
issues associated with governance
to sort of guides at guard rails for the
applications development that might be
happening in your organization
with that I may ask Stuart
let's move on through
the next
phase which is a poll question for you
in the audience
I'm asking
what has stopped you from engaging in an
AI uh
expertise program like this in the past
because you haven't found one that
covers the type of topics that you feel
you'll need as an executive managing AI
programs for your organization is it
um because you don't think that you
would end up with practical examples
that would be able to demonstrate your
your new skills
is it because you don't feel comfortable
just learning from pre-recorded lectures
or is it a time constraint
so I'm going to leave this open for
another 10 seconds or so
let's see the numbers continuing to
change a little bit and we'll close in
five
or
free
two
two one
so the major concerns on our in our
audience today are uh
not feeling that you would get practical
examples that you would be able to
demonstrate your skills
um or the concept grasp your Concepts
not finding a comprehensive curriculum
and not feeling comfortable learning
from pre-recorded videos
yeah
with that I'm going to move into what
makes this program
um
different from those problems so it has
a comprehensive curriculum
it will talk to you about the different
aspects of AI or decision making in
different sectors or
horizontals of your company
um different applications
online live discussions that supplement
the self-paced learning so that you are
not relying solely on recorded videos
integrated assignments and quizzes that
will help you develop your your skills
in a demonstrable way and flexible
timing so what I'm going to do is
and share with you what Don had to say
about
this program
in just a moment
one of the things that is a bit
different about Wharton programming in
the online uh
efforts of professional development is
we tend to to focus on issues that are
not settled science so basically the
Wharton School doesn't present oh here's
a a series of courses in learning how to
program an R to accomplish certain kinds
of activities you know that settled
science
what we do is we draw on
frankly the top academic Minds in the
world who are involved with research
around questions that are open and
they're unsettled and what we try to do
is set a table so that on one side of
the table we have the top Minds from
Academia and on the other side of the
table we're hoping to draw the top Minds
from business practice that would be the
people on this call and we're we're of
the opinion that it's in the
conversation between the two sides of
that table that new knowledge emerges to
help inform uh responses to these
unanswered questions that are on the
table regarding where is AI going
it's moving very fast
the
programs of study that we have been
involved with even last year is very
different from what we're facing this
year
a year or two ago the issue of machine
learning through structured application
of knowledge experts was wasn't at the
front burner in terms of of work being
done in this field today what's on the
front burner is actually
unstructured machine learning that is an
application of algorithms for improving
forecasting capability
at a scale and a speed of use of data
that that actually makes it difficult
for human beings to follow and those
issues now are Irrelevant in trying to
understand
again some of those ethical
considerations that I pointed to earlier
so it's moving fast it's changing on a
regular basis this is what excites
people who are on the faculty at Wharton
and the opportunity to engage with
informed practitioners from around the
world such as we're hoping to convene in
this program is uh
is is Hope is helpful in terms of moving
that research agenda forward but also
helpful in trying to fill in the some
detail around what's really working in
this space as we know it today so the
faculty can bring research from the
organizations they're currently working
with we're hoping you bring context from
your own firm your own role your own
uh industry to
test what we are suggesting might be
possible so in that regard we will have
lots of online discussions to supplement
the self-paced part of the of the
curriculum we hope to have uh to expose
you to a variety of Industries in a
variety of examples of how these new
technologies are beginning to to prove
their worth we will have assignments and
quizzes around what we know now
regarding the state of the art in Ai and
machine learning but the intent here is
to provide busy professionals like
yourselves or people who might be
actively involved with raising a young
family a chance to fit a program of
study of this type into your busy
lifestyle so we're looking for oh three
to five hours a week over the course of
the next three months for you to explore
some pre-recorded material that'll set
the stage for interaction that happens
in the in the course in other modalities
come on I might ask you for the next
slide Stuart sure
yeah and
the culmination of that three-month
period is your the certificate you earn
from Wharton online
that um certifies that you covered this
material that you've engaged in the
program actively and that you've
gained understanding of the concepts so
worked with those case studies and
you've also as Don said
brought your experience to the
discussion so that you can then take
away from it
um insights into how AI can be applied
in your own organization
the uh
online experience
um
are different from just self-paced moocs
or massively online open courses that uh
that Don referred to before so
um
it's a entirely different experience
right Tom
uh yes yeah and in fact the
um
what we're hoping to do is to um
is to open the floor for considerations
and examples and questions and
applications that you all might have
been exposed to to complement uh the
Consulting engagements and uh projects
that were funded on campus that are
driving uh the work of our AI oriented
research centers I mentioned earlier we
have faculty from the people analytics
initiative who have joined this course
to look at the applications of AI to
decisions around
matters associated with human resource
management we have also faculty from our
customer analytics initiative we'll be
looking at the new ways to uh that
companies are using unstructured data to
inform marketing related decisions and
as I'm I mentioned earlier we have
faculty from our Stevenson honor for
innovation in finance to talk to the
issues associated with new applications
of of AI machine learning for financial
services I might take a second to answer
Conrad's question here who posted in the
Q a uh the question if the class is
designed for management level then
there's no need to learn the details of
practical exposure but if the class is
designed for the working level then
hand-on practices are needed which one
is this so I will challenge your
assumption Conrad the I think the well
our experience at Wharton has been and
we've seen this backed up with research
done both at McKinsey and TCS is that
the reason most business analytics
projects fail and most of them fail in
terms of delivering value for the
investment is the lack of someone who
stands between the management level
and the Practical level of data
warehousing and application development
someone who acts as a translator between
the senior Executives or those who have
p l responsibility at your firm who have
in their minds working hypotheses a
theory of their firm of why in a mature
or competitive
Marketplace a customer would pick
services and products from our company
versus some of their competitors there's
a there's a theory a hypothesis around
that question that only someone who is
in a transliteral can tease out by
informing a question shaping a question
so that data can actually be applied to
check that hypothesis and see if it's
actually true we've gone through
multiple
unprecedented changes in our management
of our firms and our economies over the
last three years first putting large
segments of our economy into a deep
freeze and now slowly defrosting
components of the economy in a world
that has learned a whole lot about
managing Supply chains about
communicating in manners that are not
face to face and in
addressing a Marketplace that is now
entirely
disrupted
in the space of retail sales in a way
that builds on disruptions that happened
before covet so in all of these
uncertain circumstances the the tried
and true knowledge that informs the boss
that informs senior people at your
organization Isn't So tried and true
anymore and requires exposure to what's
the data really say something that may
have worked five years ago for
positioning your firm for success in a
crowded field may not be working today
uh and if I can just just use again one
example of that in the retail space
at least in North America we have seen
extraordinary disruption to
organizations who have large uh retail
Footprints in Suburban shopping malls
and in cities around the country who
have uh found themselves facing
bankruptcy names like Sears and Neiman
Marcus and many other big box stores are
in trouble
and yet in the midst of all of this
chaos you see these extraordinary Rising
Stars like for example Lululemon on
Trader Joe's and uh uh Sephora who are
actually rapidly growing in the same
retail space that has seen such
devastation
what is uh what we are seeing at Wharton
in studying these successes our
organizations that have learned how to
apply uh data to inform an omni-channel
retail strategy and that kind of work
can't be done by the wisened gray-haired
here I am I got a lot of gray hair
myself why isn't old gray-haired
leadership of the organization nor can
be handled by The Young Turks who are
fresh out of engineering school and
ready to crank up those Tableau systems
for creating beautiful data charts it
takes someone in the middle someone who
understands the value of Tableau and of
other ways to represent data and to
extract data and to gather data along
with someone who can talk to the c-suite
executives and and extract the
underlying assumptions behind the
decision they make on a daily basis
that's what McKenzie identified as the
critical role in a successful business
analytics project and as I say TCS did
as well so that's what we're trying to
shape this course is for in between
those two positions Conrad so it's uh it
is intended to look practically at who's
succeeding but we're hoping to have a
conversation around
how this success may or may not apply to
your context and what it is that's
needed in a sense of organizational
capacity both in your I.T space and in
your trading space and in your
investment in cloud-based services
to to test those hypotheses in this new
emergent uncertain world or all living
in at the moment so you don't rely on on
real world business case studies uh and
the professors will be bringing to the
table or people who are you know getting
their hands dirty every day in this
space this course isn't about teaching R
but everyone I think who's a teaching in
this uh teaching and from the Wharton
School in this course uh is you know
uses are and a whole variety of
different uh
um data uh tools for extracting
information from unstructured data uh in
their regular research as I say R is the
preferred tool at Warden but there are
many many tools this isn't a uh this the
the issue isn't tools and issue is in
data the issue is extracting
intelligence from data
yeah
um that also touched on it and and
brings us to
discussing why Wharton why
the Wharton School is
the best choice for
engaging in this investigation of AI
foreign
from the point of view of uh of a market
positioning uh that the uh the our Dean
Erica James uh is uh interested in in
putting in the marketplace so that
people who might have the luxury of
choosing between uh an education at
Wharton or Stanford or Harvard or NCR or
uh ISB
Singapore management University all
these great schools around the world why
would you uh ever uh be interested in
engaging with the Wharton School or
sending your son and daughter or
daughter to an MBA program in a place
like Wharton
and I think the answer to that or one of
the answers to that is the fact that
Wharton uh on a scale of being poetic to
being Quant oriented and I I use those
terms uh because of a kind of a famous
MBA blog that helps people pick MBA
schools to go to earlier in their career
that's called poets and quads
and on one end uh one could point to
Harvard as being the most poetic I think
of the classic big name Business Schools
in that their engagement with cases and
with senior leadership around the world
in intimate conversations around what
succeeded in their careers is
extraordinary and wonderful and a great
experience that's not this course that's
not what Warden does what we do is focus
on metrics and data and financial models
and projections and the empirical truth
of what's going on so to give your a
flavor of that
when the Wharton School was founded in
1881 as the first business school
that was based around a college or
university in the world that was sort of
an invention in 1881 by Joseph Warden
and his work with some of the uh
economists and lawyers who were working
at the University of Pennsylvania at the
time to build out what was going to
become the curriculum under for
undergraduate business degrees and then
later for mbas in those days there was a
great deal of engineering happening
around
canals and waterways in the North
American continent which were critical
infrastructure for the growth of this
sort of Second Industrial Revolution
that was happening in North America at
the time and one of the major projects
of course was the effort to connect the
Pacific and Atlantic Oceans through the
Panama Canal well the government of uh
Teddy Roosevelt turned to Wharton
professors to help understand uh the
forecasts Financial modeling and P L
projections around this extraordinary
engineering feat called the Panama Canal
and he we turned on turned he turned to
Warden School faculty for helping inform
those decisions around how charges and
tariffs were being developed for
shipping because we had studied uh
similar activity in the North American
canals the Erie Canal systems that
connected the Northeast for example so
we've been involved with big data and
and deep into understanding forecasting
and predictive modeling since the 19th
century and then through the 20th
century
Wharton was the campus where the concept
of life insurance took shape the idea
that you could put a dollar value you on
a person's life and
develop Financial security systems for
for that the value of that life that you
could look at the entire functioning of
an economy as a series of sectors who
could be measured to develop
outcome metrics like gross national
product all of that work was done at the
Wharton School the develop of marketing
development of marketing science largely
accomplished by the work of Paul Green
some of the work around conjun analysis
done in the 1960s that moved marketing
from being a largely creative exercise
again a poetic exercise to a metrics
driven approach to understanding what
works uh in in marketing and what
doesn't so it's been a long history
almost 150 years of being deeply
involved with the application of data
that is the reason why I can confidently
tell you that I think of all of the of
schools who put programs of study
together for you to look at
if what your
driving need is is associated with the
kinds of examples we've been trying to
describe the application of large data
sets uh studied and analyzed using
state-of-the-art tools to inform real
world decisions that are being made on a
daily basis
then I think the Wharton School is as
well prepared as any partner you could
find to help you in that exploration but
I will say it's an exploration it's not
a matter of settled science it's not
like we're teaching you calculus we're
exploring together as a community of
inquiry
a topic that is what we consider to be
both emergence unsettled science and
critically important
those are the topics that draw attention
from the the 250 members of the standing
faculty at the Wharton School from whom
we draw to uh present this class
great
good
so I hope that gave you a an
appreciation of
the value of Wharton
uh
value that Orton brings to this
investigation this
kind of
education in what AI can do for
businesses from the managerial
perspective you do not have to have any
prior knowledge or experience in
programming or math this is not a
technology course and we had a couple of
questions coming in about that I'll
discuss that in the Q a but this is a
program more oriented towards c-suite
Executives senior managers mid-level
managers Consultants people who need to
understand how AI be applied in business
from a slightly bigger picture
perspective
so with that I'm going to ask
a question
uh
before we get the question c-suite
Executives senior Executives Business
Leaders and managers managers and
leaders who want to increase their own
capabilities so if you're looking to um
understand how you can improve the
operation of your business applying AI
technology or how you can become a
stronger manager by understanding
applications of AI this is a great
program for you and
with that
I will ask this poll question
oops
what level of your career are you
currently in are you uh currently a
student or uh are you early in your
career
or are you more senior
so let's let this open for about 15
seconds
if the numbers have stopped changing so
I'm going to close it in five just to
give you an extra time
and here are the numbers
um so more than two-thirds of our
audience are more seasoned folks with
five or more years of experience
um
with about a little less than the third
who are
in the earlier phases of their career
so
talk a little bit about how this program
prepares you what it consists of
um so
it consists of
three-month program it takes uh four
main modules uh
five main modules I'm sorry the first
one is foundations
a big data Ai and machine learning to
give you a kind of grounding in the
terminology the technology what the
principles are again not um
not
reliant on you understanding mathematics
and programming but to give you the kind
of background that allows you to
understand what is possible uh with AI
technology and machine learning
technology today what big data is and
where the information and insights can
be found in it
um then we move on to the the four
modules first in marketing looking at AI
case studies in the marketing World
moving on to AI in the finance domain
then Ai and Human Resource Management in
the last module very important is ethics
and governance
factors that you need to consider when
looking to apply AI within your
organization so that you do it in a
positive way and don't open your
organization to liabilities because
again along the way you have master
classes that you can take with Wharton
faculty in addition to the discussion
sessions and you earn a
certificate from Wharton online
executive
education
you will learn from a host of
Wharton faculty who will present
different topics in the different
modules
um Professor hasnagar is a
operations information as is Professor
Lou and Professor tombe they'll talk
about
the use of AI in
various operational aspects across the
different
areas of marketing finance and
HR
Professor Capelli and Professor Bidwell
will be talking more about HR
Professor Roberts about the finance
aspects Professor ayengar about the
marketing module
and Professor werbach very important
we'll talk about
legal ethical and governance issues
these are the the people who will be
facilitating the discussion and bringing
out the case studies and helping you to
present
your
use cases for your organization and how
AI might
be applicable to those
going to share with you this gentleman
who will talk about
the actual online learning environment
so he's going to describe one of our
partner programs with another University
but this will give you an idea of what
it like to use the online learning
environment
welcome to Simply learn and our unique
online boot camp where millions of
professionals have gotten the skills
they need to succeed there are two
components that make our online boot
camp approach so successful great
content from the world's leading
technology companies practitioners and
universities and a unique and
proprietary learning environment that
was specifically designed for high
engagement and learner support when you
log into simply learn you set the course
timeline that meets your busy work and
home schedule and keep track of your
progress every step of the way we'll
help you stay on plan with automated and
24 7 human support at the core of our
programs are our live virtual classrooms
where you interact Real Time with
trainers that are recognized leaders in
their field there you'll review key
Concepts get questions answered and
interact with your peers the important
reports on the audience if you notice
our demographics this is super useful
especially if you're running ads for
example you could do it on social media
later you'll learn social media
marketing too
by looking at these numbers you'll be
able to understand the age range of
people that you should be targeting you
know what you could just focus only on
that age category show your
advertisements to them very useful
that's not all you get to learn from
faculty at Global universities and
Industry experts via master classes as
ask your questions to top industry
leaders in exclusive ask me anything
sessions so uh there's another
interesting question on the chat box and
say that oh to optimize in YouTube you
could use the rising session of Google
Trends and optimize it okay so let's go
back to here right here where it says
web searches and you can see that
there's going to be the YouTube searches
okay so now you can see that the YouTube
searches is going to be so there's a
option uh under not just web search and
there's going to be a YouTube search
okay so just go ahead and click on user
search and you should be able to
optimize your search results
so what is Instagram app Instagram apps
refer to when we come across any sort of
original video
apps would appear within those video
contents so you would need caught when
you are watching an original video and
leave you a video app and then go back
to the original video content
we believe people learn best by doing go
beyond practice tackle practical
problems with multiple projects and
simulations and work on a real world
Capstone project that you can showcase
to Future employers your learning isn't
restricted to just live classes explore
our highly effective self-learning
videos and other resources to fine-tune
your learning and remain up to date
always you can focus on different
learning approaches by subject to
personalize the overall learning
experience to your learning style and
needs at the end of it all you get to
walk away with globally recognized
certificates from top universities for
the program leading companies for
specialized courses and simply learn
come on in experience professional
learning like you've never done before
get started today
foreign
just to give you an idea of what the
online learning environment is of course
the nature of this program won't have a
lot of
uh
projects
no coding exercises of that type of
thing but it will have the live
interaction and discussion assessments
um
you'll see the tools that you have for
managing your progress through the
through the program so with that I'm
going to ask based on what you've seen
so far are you interested in enrolling
in the program
and we'll leave this open for just about
15 seconds or so since it's a yes or no
question
we're going to close it in about five
seconds
all right
in the pool
and
about 80 percent of our audience are
interested in enrolling so I'm going to
share with you how that works
enrollment steps are very
straightforward because we are the
delivery partner for Wharton uh you
email us at ask us simplylearn.net put
that information into the chat
so that you can
have that email at your fingertips
putting into the chat the
program page
through which you can get more
information about the program and
contact us and also the direct
email address
that's in the chat box now
um so we will review
um
the your match to the the program
prerequisites
your level of interest and aptitude for
this particular program to make sure
that you're committed to succeeding in
it and we'll send you the email with
your admission offer the next program
actually the next cohort starts today
and probably is a little bit late for
you to get started on that but we will
have another one
coming up in March and
the cost of this is three thousand
dollars flat including taxes
um ask your employer about tuition
reimbursement if this is something that
is for your current job
responsibilities your employer May
defray summer all the cost
that's their policy
um
and
for more information about how to enroll
or specifics ask us at simplylearn.net
um
for those of you who said you are
interested I'm curious to know if this
is something you want to do
right away or
are looking to do further down the road
I'll bet if you contacted us immediately
we could get you into that February
cohort starting today
leave this open for another five seconds
so
about 40 percent of our respondents said
they would like to do this uh
starting within the next couple of
months either immediately or a March
April time frame
um
and the rest of you are looking further
down the road in either case I would
strongly recommend you contact us and
ask us simplylearn.net
um
if you're looking further down the road
we'll keep you in touch with you and
advise you on future cohorts
right now I'm going to start taking your
questions that have been coming in
just a moment
Daniel asked for more examples and use
cases a good question for the
Folks At The Learning Consultants would
ask us at simplylearn.net may be able to
help you with more specifics of the use
cases beyond what Don mentioned in his
remarks
um
the length of the course of the three
months
look
and your time commitment during that is
about three to five hours a week which
includes the the live interaction in the
Seminars the uh
uh live discussions and master classes
and some of the material will be
pre-recorded uh Preparatory material
that you watch in between on whatever
schedule whatever time frame you want
the platform is available to you 24 7.
um
yeah and Joe you can ask the learning
Consultants what the actual timings are
in terms of what hours
they hold the live sessions each week
to get their evenings or weekends
um
a question here from
face to face uh impact of chat GPT
embarred on businesses
um
so that's a great question that
you would want to ask during this this
course but
um
how will different corporations use it
will corporate control access
I think one of the the
interesting things about these tools is
many of them are open
um
not necessarily open source but
certainly open to
um
different applications and uses so it's
going to be difficult for any
particular corporation or entity to
control where and how they're used
um
and that brings up certainly ethical
issues we've all heard about the
questions about whether
it's ethical to use chat GPT to write
your
exam papers for uh
master's degree or that type of thing so
um
this is going to be an important topic
of discussion
and how would you use this
type of technology in order to um
prove your operational workflow we had a
question about using
Ai and content marketing
um
so
will for example chat GPT be able to
generate
content
more efficiently what will that do to
the role of
human content writers copywriters and
such
um
how will the questions specifically
asked about Google ranking and how will
um
things like chat GPT interacting with
Google's ranking algorithms create
feedback loops that
will cause rapid content slewing
this to chase higher rankings and things
like that that will be part of the I
think the discussion in the marketing
module
um
because that's an important topic
will the course touch based on AI and
creative decisions and strategies and
legal aspects for AI so on the legal
aspect certainly there's a module on
legal implications ethical implications
governance that's an important aspect of
this program and then Ai and creative
decisions will be part of I think the
discussion in terms of the marketing
module about
um
how AI can help you
create marketing campaigns and that type
of thing so
uh moving back to the other questions
I can't answer the question about it
what percentage of the course curriculum
will focus on content marketing
uh and so forth but I can say that of
the five modules one of them is devoted
to marketing so
the extent that you want to bring up
those topics in that module and discuss
that with
um the professor of marketing
Dot